turning now to the world climate summit
it's scheduled to end today and
negotiations on some crucial issues are
going right down to the wire one of
those issues a pledge from nearly 200
countries to accelerate the phase out of
coal another sticking point billions of
dollars in financial aid for poorer
nations however there's some good news
the u.s and china made an unexpected
deal ahead of a virtual meeting between
president biden and china's president xi
this monday mark phillips is covering
the climate summit in glasgow scotland
for mark good morning
good morning tony well as you say we're
into the final hours of this conference
without it having achieved its major
objectives there has though been one
major surprise here and that has caused
something of a glimmer of hope
the chief climate negotiators of the
united states and china have made deals
in the past but given the current chill
between beijing and washington no
meeting of mines was expected here yet
that's what happened
when it comes to climate change says
there is more agreement between the u.s
and china than divergence
cooperation is the only way to get this
job done
there's not a lot of meat on the bones
of the u.s china deal but beijing has
for the first time admitted it must cut
its output of methane one of the most
powerful greenhouse gases as for
decarbonizing its economy and the rest
working groups will be set up apart from
that deal there's been disappointment in
tuvalu we are living the realities of
climate change the foreign minister of
the south pacific island nation of
tuvalu simon coffey summed it up do
something before this whole country
becomes unlivable
yet the hope that delegates here would
agree concrete plans to cut greenhouse
gas emissions and limit global warming
to 1.5 degrees celsius has proved a
false one the latest estimate is that
the real cuts promised so far would
still allow the earth to heat up to
around 2.7 degrees with all the heat
waves droughts fires storms and floods
that that would bring
this conference failed in another
objective as well to come up with the
money promised to developing nations to
compensate them for not using fossil
fuels and for the damage caused by
severe weather a hundred billion dollars
a year was promised
but aubry wilson of the small island
nations delegation here says they're
still waiting for it well we are very
disappointed because it's a promise
made a promise failed you want them to
show you the money
that too yes
there's still time for a miracle of
course a last-minute breakthrough but i
have to say there's very little hint of
a miracle in the air here just too much
carbon dioxide nate
mark in glasgow thank you